[Music]
have done so much in your career so far
in drag
what's still left on the drag queen
career bucket list well for me um I love
being a musician I love being able to
put out music movies like a jigsaw in
the farther you go if you miss some
pieces you never really know it's kind
of weird though cuz in the folk music
Americana Country world where I've great
music I think because I'm a crossdresser
I'm still sort of on the other side of
the plate of glass being like you know
but um forward to maybe being taken
slightly more seriously by people who
maybe I'm a little close minded to what
we do think about drag is it's fun and I
think that there's everybody's like well
drag is not for me we'll do like mrs.
Doubtfire
do you like Madea do you like the movie
white chicks they guess what [ __ ] you
do like drag watching drag doesn't make
you gay no listen to Selena doesn't make
you Hispanic journey it doesn't make any
sense
you can like something from another
culture and you can be a visitor and
still see feels anchored in who you are
Darien Lake always says when I go to the
hospital no one thinks I'm a doctor and
you know she probably goes to the
hospital lot she probably does Wow
I think you know why yeah she does a lot
of friends have babies you know what I
don't have time to deal with this right
now do you see more reality TV in your
future yeah I like reality TV I like
doing anything sort of spur the moment
comedy I mean the Trixie and Katya show
on Vice land that's technically a
reality show no I don't know like
watching Courtney on Big Brother I
couldn't do anything that was just
personality based but also I'm a
terrible competitor as we've learned so
like stress you need structured without
a competition factor yeah I just want
someone to turn on a webcam on my house
while I'm pulling the pan have you ever
had that moment where you're like I got
to step away for a minute know I'm a
crazy person drag doesn't make me crazy
if anything drag keeps me anchored in
reality cut to me in six months living
in a tree house somewhere quit dragging
chains my name there's the reality show
yeah Alaskan bush people it's Alaska
living in the woods called Alaska is a
bush people Oh
I'll guess each week coming to visit her
yeah living in a tree house yeah okay
well maybe season two of the Trixie and
crotches show maybe we'll move to a tree
house I'm into that there you go you can
just do the man on the street segments
by shouting down to say bye just hoping
a while a wild boar runs by and I can be
like hey Stephanie what's your favorite
color you know whatever we're talking
about right yeah there has not been any
favorite colors episode yet we haven't
run out of ideas that severely if we get
to my favorite color episode please stop
us